chaplin mais ça a bercé mon enfance je
lui suis très reconnaissant de ses rires
d'enfants et j'ai eu la chance de les
garder un petit peu de les garder ses
rires d'enfants des jeux séries rendre
mon mandat quand c'est bon mais je me
rappelle sur les bancs de viser non du
petit patronat juge était sur les bancs
et monsieur le curé qui projetait des
films de chaplin uniquement et on en est
c'est à cette époque qu'il va être si
bonne mandarine sous jacente et les
mandarines et ont renvoyé à leurs cages
déployer c'était fantastique tous ses
petits fils de ces petits films en fin
de courbe étages et j'ai placé ma fille
j'ai passé ma vie au père du cinéma
bercé comme démarche appelée tu pars
leurs ailes et redit aussi par tous ses
grands mais chaplin est ce que votre
avis est le plus grand c'est le parfait
mais parfait point de vue je sais de
perfectionnement et comme les techniques
et que maintenant c'est énorme
est ce que en regardant jouer jacklin
vous avez appris quelque chose pour vous
même pour votre profession oui j'ai ab
j'ai appris des mines oui le timing
c'est un mot anglais qui épatera
deuxième enfant celle ci s'ils se
croient que c'est le mouvement le
mouvement d'un film le mouvement c'est à
dire aller vite il ya pas de crue il n'y
a jamais de peux pas me blesser j'ai
appris ça certains reprochaient à
chaplin
or si l'on peut reprocher quelque chose
d'en faire un peu trop olona quelle
horreur c'était merveilleuse qu'il fait
vous savez ceux qui en rigueur raimu ou
sur des huguenots fait trop mais c'était
rien du tout c'était c'était charmant
c'est pas en faire les gens dans la rue
en font beaucoup plus plaisant dans les
restaurants font beaucoup plus les gens
dit nos hommes politiques font en font
des tonnes
car c'est mauvais et elle a ses charmes
des tonnes de chaplin c'est une petite
plume rose qui volent